I did I had no idea oh yeah that's one
of those strangest things that's ever
happened to me you know I often wrote
dispatches and emails and letters from
different war zones just because I
didn't have time to write to all my
friends individually and say what it's
like and I was getting tons of emails
from people saying you know you say for
you okay what's going on in Iraq how bad
is it so i would put together you know a
few paragraphs or maybe a page or two of
my impressions and email it to them and
i think this is what i did in September
2004 accept things were really really
bad in Iraq security was deteriorating
our house had just been bombed and I had
to evacuate and you know people were
getting kidnapped so you know I kind of
told it as it was and I told it with a
lot of emotion because I thought I was
talking to my friends I didn't I wasn't
writing a piece for The Wall Street
Journal and I sent it off and I think
about a few days later my inbox had
something like a hundred and seventy six
females from random people from around
the world that I didn't know asking me
if I had written this email and so I was
like what's what's going on and how did
this you know get to different people
and then it was posted on blogs and on
websites and printed across the world
and different newspapers and became this
strange sensation and people kind of
saying you know we didn't know it was
this bad in Iraq we didn't know that it
was this dangerous and what had happened
was apparently most of my friends had
forwarded the email around their friends
had forward it and it just you know went
all over the place I think the response
that I got from people the outpouring of
emotion and the outpouring of emails and
letters that I got made me think that
maybe there's a personal story to be
told about Iraq and one that was more
reflections and impressions rather than
just the chronology of what had happened
politically and militarily
early you know but I to be honest I also
came under a lot of pressure after that
email you know there were the sort of
far left saying oh the media sensors the
news and you know here was praising me
for writing what I had thought but also
saying oh how come you don't say this in
your published pieces and the far right
saying you're biased and you know you
know you're not fit to cover Iraq which
I think both accusations were untrue we
had been saying that stuff just in a
journalistic objective way and my
published pieces were not biased at all
so yeah so that that was that in itself
was an interesting experience